my next guest was a standout on Dancing
with the Stars last year and we all know
and love her from nine seasons on the
office
let's get Kate Flannery on the line
right now hi hey Kate girl yeah I know
you look great
we both look a little different than the
last time we saw each other just a
little bit yeah it just happens during
these I thought we were still doing the
Halloween thing last time I saw you had
a wig on so you know what you know
challenge accepted I think on our show
we should do costumes more often but no
you didn't have to wear costumes so so I
didn't want you to think I just you know
I'm it's I haven't been to the beauty
parlor either so the mustache is full
well earlier this year you were on
Dancing with the Stars tour right that's
a huge tour I was I got to do 45 of our
54 shows but then of course we got yeah
but you know I'm really proud of myself
I'm 55 years old I'm like a 15 year old
trapped in a 55 year old body Kelly I
mean aren't we all
it was so exciting though like we huge
audiences you know I mean so many great
fans it was really insane it was really
wonderful yeah I mean and what's cool
though is at least y'all got to do most
of the tour like you know a lot of
people didn't get to do anything that's
really cool of it and like for people to
get to come see y'all live and like it's
so entertaining what you do and it's
such an athletic thing that you know all
of us like close our eyes and like yeah
I'm totally Jennifer Grey and Dirty
Dancing but like oh I feel like not
happening okay wait I have to show you
something cuz okay you sent me this doll
and everybody there's been a lot of
people doing like tributes w because we
looked at there are a lot of people to
do tributes to you and that's such a
compliment but this is amazing it's a
Meredith casual Friday doll that's what
it pop Funko pop doll I know I know we
could have a little conversation I got
mine out you know what I they just
started working on the office this past
year and I was literally at my my
boyfriend's son's high school graduation
and Everett and we stopped
go store in Everett Washington and they
were like hey come with me and then they
showed me the Michael Scott Funko pop
they're like we're starting so one year
later casual Friday Meredith appears
that's not that's so cool this I don't
know if you've seen this yet but this is
a chalk painting of Meredith oh my god
all chalk it's from the light of the
office from season season nine one
Meredith shoot I look like Benjamin
Franklin but that's okay okay that is so
funny
oh my god but that's - like impact
someone enough to do that on like I I'm
not even I don't even know how these
people do this like chalk art it doesn't
seem to me really I mean coming from a
quilter that's totally not even average
I'm like basic very good this is amazing
like you're a more your ear immortalized
in needlepoint
which is not easy that is so cool yes
Jamie that she wasn't a dancer for the
Stars fan that's me and my dance partner
Pasha posh cough yeah she gave it to me
on the tour I actually have a copy of it
- she made a few of them that's so cool
I mean I received many gifts so you know
like in just from fans cuz over the
years and like that's really cool that
takes time that's not just like yes
she's met her yeah we met I think we met
in North Carolina one of the shows and
maybe this crazy Meredith doll which I
think it's really more like a Barbie
doll because my face is has never been
this beautiful no that's amazing
I love it it's so funny like how people
you know they they're like oh I love
this person how in in their own line of
work they kind of you know get to kind
of lift you up and praise someone that
they love that it's impacted them or
made them laugh or you know they've been
able to be their escapism it's cool how
that comes out many different forms I'm
really you know I'm so grateful I love
that and I love that you you see that
like it's such a I don't know I know we
both met people or know people that
forget how blessed they are and and and
you know aren't
the blessings and Counting the you know
mistakes or things I didn't get and it's
like it's really cool that you recognize
that like cause we're all lucky
everybody and we're all replaceable you
know I'm saying somebody could be we're
doing you know so it's it's really cool
that you you recognize it and you're
having fun that's the coolest thing
about talking to you okay every time I
talk to you you like genuinely have and
your boyfriend told me this a while back
when he was a photographer them for the
voice and he's like you and my
girlfriend have a lot in common because
we we are both very like energetic and
and I try to be positive and I try to
always focus on what I have positive
you're so great you're so country but
that's that's what I love about you as
well I think I think it's not easy and I
think people think you just come out
that way and you don't it's like
something you have to work at and and
and really you know keep perspective and
you're so cool like right back at you
but I really think getting older it's
like you neither get smarter you get
Dumber and it gets easier I think I
don't know I think I've always kind of
been this person but like for some
reason it's it's it's gotten easier like
the older I get and it's not that you
don't care it's that you care about
what's important I think right right
well you know I mean these times are so
so challenging for so many reasons I
mean I feel like it's you know it's it's
time to focus on the change that's
happening in the world and accept that
there's so many things that are not
right I made a decision to donate part
of my cameo proceeds to the
n-double-a-cp
and just just and I feel like and
whatever more I can do I I'm learning no
that's what I did - I'm that was my big
thing I was like okay so instead of you
know I I do what I can and where I can
but I think a lot of it is and a lot of
the problem is is that don't try and
understand like you're never gonna
understand like where someone's coming
from if it's such a different
perspective from you such a different
life such a different view just listen
and listen to them on how maybe things
can improve and I think if we all just
did that a little more you know it it
would work and we'd finally see the
change that so many people have fought
and died for Kelly you're awesome
you are too I love talking thank you for
doing my show again subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going